y equals sine X plus cos Xu and lettuce
I've left off a lot of information of
this graph even though I'm going to
refer to it I haven't put on any
intercepts because this graph is about
to get very busy very fast okay so let's
have a look at the information we know
and then go from there so for instance
these graphs of sine and cosine so I
actually haven't into a knowledge of
where these things pass through the axis
right for instance scientist intercepts
at 0 180 and 360 cosine has intercepts
at 90 and 70 and you can go on from
there right now we're going to use those
piece of information because when I add
these two together really what this
means is you know each graph has its
height one of the combined heights of
birds bats together example here at the
origin I know I should say x equals 0
right the sine graph C equals 0 but the
COS graph is equal to 1 so when I add up
0 plus 1 I get 1
that's all passing through that point
there's a few other points that are just
the same right for instance cosine goes
down here and it's 0 and causes X is
equal 0 when X is equal to what angle
when X is equal on angle 90 degrees 90
reason they're at the same point because
the symmetry here sine 90 is equal to 1
some pasta needs to be there now if you
want to spots where I could see that but
in Reverse right here at 180 degrees in
the middle sine is equal to 0 but cosine
is equal to minus 1 so I'm down down
here ok um let's see here I've got sine
ah sorry take a back cosine equals 0
sine equal to minus 1 so and last one
which we can take for an intercept is
right there at 360 degrees right I'm
back where I started
in fact which is exactly what I should
expect okay so whatever my some of these
graphs are going to be it's gonna pass
through all these blue points there's a
few guys I can put on there as well for
instance the next most interesting point
points are the points of intersection
right you can see there are two of them
the first one is easy
what is this point of intersection it's
45 degrees because sine of 45 and cause
of 45 are both equal to 100 to 102 it's
about 0.707 okay now I don't need to
know all that much about it
like 1 over 2 to know that he are they
both the state right so if I add two
numbers that are put the same it'll just
be double right it'll be 100 2 plus 1
over 2 which is 2 1 root 2 or on what's
2 1 root 2 that's just rude too isn't it
ok so this is why I gave you I asked
reduce an extra space up here
rich is about 1.4 okay so if you go up
about 40% that should be where the
square root of 2 is okay and at x equals
45 degrees I'm passing through there
okay now again using the tremendous
symmetry that you can see here right
there's another point over here where I
get exactly the same scenario we want
some difference I don't have one over to
do I I have minus 1 over 2 so when I had
this together I'm gonna get minus
ratures down here
okay now this bit is a little bit tricky
okay and let's see how you went pick up
a rule huh okay and then depending how
accurately you have drawn your graph you
should be able to find two points two
points just like we just did two points
there where for example here's the first
one where the sine graph is above the
axis the same distance that the COS
graph is below the axis let me say that
again there's a point somewhere in here
right where this positive distance
that's up to sign is the same as this
negative distance right so if you get a
ruler you want to be able to sort of run
it along here and be able to work out
it's about there it should be about
halfway okay sorry
where I've got a positive distance and a
negative that are the same she canceled
out shouldn't they I should get zero
okay 135 very good and we should expect
that because it's between 90 and 180
okay and because of this wonderful
symmetry I'm going to get exactly the
same situation for a big key up halfway
between what's that gonna be that's 270
and 360 so I guess it'd be 315 315 okay
this is enough this is enough of a shape
to actually connect this do you can see
I'm going to get this sort of up/down
kind of shape right if you join the dots
do the best you can
well use your imagination there we go
it's pretty close okay so what have I
got here
okay this blue graph at last is y equals
sine X plus cos x okay now that I've got
that there now I could put on the
intercepts that I'm interested in which
we just mentioned right I think we said
135 degrees and 315 so there's the
intercepts
now this is really great because now I
can see the whole shape of it and here's
why I asked you to put an extra little
space on the left-hand side okay
what would happen over here and what
would happen here and the answer is
because the two things you put together
sine and cosine are both periodic 360
degrees right there's a copy every 360
degrees so therefore this sum when you
put them together also or to be copied
every 360 degrees right so in fact
what's happening over here is exactly
the same as what's happening over here I
should be coming down kind of like this
okay and continue I suppose so what do
we got here right in conclusion how
would you describe this blue shape that
we've drawn whether Jesus is right
looks kinda like it's um it's periodic
right it's periodic I hope it's a lot of
replicas much the problems I know are
not periodic right looks to me like it's
just an overgrown sine curve right
I could Irma grow because look I'm not
between -1 1 anymore am i I I'm so grown
I'm from minus 3 to 2 root 2 doing the
same oscillating thing so the first
thing is the amplitude has been widened
or Portola okay that's the able to UM
that's very quick it's also being sort
of moved over right because cause it
starts at its maximum whoops I'm sorry
cause starts its maximum then comes down
sine starts at the middle this blue
graph starts neither at the middle or at
the top right um it just kind of starts
midway right so something's been moved
over this should really be the start
shouldn't it okay but I've sort of
shifted over there so that was our
visual approach what is this actual
graph okay well before we approach it
algebraically let me just conclude from
all of this with the sentence right this
is the sum of two trig functions right
but sine and cosine are different from
tan and cotton blah blah blah
and as they're also what would call wave
functions wave functions because
amazingly there's shaping a wave okay so
what I've got here site express conduct
is this sum of two wave functions the
sum of two wave okay
this is what you do in like in science
when you have lazy of them so the sum of
two weight functions is another way of
function right you see it's just another
one its peak up right
he's another wave function but with two
different qualities that we just pointed
out vertically it has a different
amplitude
but also it's been shifted horizontally
right so what we call that is phase
right different amplitude and a
different phase okay so we're going to
find what this amplitude and phase are
by tackling this with a surprising
friend so